la ministre de la santé on dit que c'est
la gauche du gouvernement attention
c'est de gauche pareil on a vraiment vu
va faire 3 milliards dit-elle
d'économies sur l'hôpital public 3
milliards d'euros sur l'hôpital public
elle dit maintenant on va financer
l'hôpital à la performance vous savez ce
que c'est la performance à l'hôpital
c'est ce qu'on appelle la durée moyenne
de séjour
on mesure il ya un contact qui vous dit
oulala attention cela sont restés trop
longtemps il faut multiplier les actes
pour obtenir des financements
et quand on est atteint d'une maladie
chronique ben on rentre dans des
hôpitaux parce qu'on est atteint d'une
maladie chronique on ne peut y rester
longtemps
mais bon on va vouloir mettre la
pression pour réduire la durée moyenne
de séjour que les gens ne restent pas
trop longtemps pour qu'on puisse
multiplier les actes et ans et à ce
moment-là améliorer le financement d'un
hôpital
c'est pas ça la santé ses passes à
l'hôpital public
l'hôpital public ça suppose qu'elle met
soignant une infirmière un médecin
puisse prendre du temps pour bien qu à d
médicaments parfois administrer des
opérations à réaliser et qui a parfois
accompagnées aussi des passions qui
peuvent être en fin de vie et expliqué
que un hôpital doit être financé à la
performance
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
allez réduire la durée moyenne de séjour
ça veut dire que vous allez mettre la
pression sur des personnels qui sont
administratifs et soignants alors qu'il
ya déjà des burnout par dizaines de
l'hôpital voilà trois milliards de
réduction
il ya des noms mais alors pourquoi vous
allez faire 5 milliards de suppression
de l'sf si vous allez demander par
ailleurs à des infirmières de bosser
plus à un aide-soignant de bosser plus
non mais ça va pas il ya un moment quand
même revient sur terre non médias
dommage vous êtes deux secondes quand
même 5 milliards 3 milliards
c'est pas les mêmes budgets vont dire
oui benoît hamon vous confondez le
budget de la sécurité sociale et le
budget de l'état à onesse confonds rien
du tout j'ai très bien que c'est pas les
mêmes budgets mais c'est indécent de
dire un malade vous resterait moins
longtemps à l'hôpital il ya une
infirmière vous gérerez plus de monde
vous serez moins nombreuses dans vote ou
moins nombreux dans votre service et en
même temps de dire aux principales
fortunes de ce pays qui eux aussi
bénéficient l'hôpital public au passage
et qui sont contents d'en bénéficier
vous paierez moins pour que les hôpitaux
se modernise vous paierez moins pour
qu'on ait des écoles partout vous
paierez moins pour qu'on ait un prof
face à 12 élèves comme le fait par
ailleurs emmanuel macron juste en essais
paix dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire vous vous paierez moins ça
ça n'est pas possible c'est un des sens